[Musique]
il ya
ça va pas trop le trac pour la première
ça c'est sûr
j'ai dit ça fait dix ans que sur les
plateaux il ya un truc infaillible pour
ça la vie tu étudies rentrent dedans
millon tulle et rentrent dedans tu
jamais le tulle et rentre dedans quel
que soit l'invité tu rentres dedans tu
rentres dedans turne de hockey
où j'ai bossé jean la halle du hard
pourquoi
ces bons ainsi j'ai besoin de rien je
t'appelle
merci d'abord
[Musique]
allô allô
ce qui se passe là tout un monde aux
côtés de quoi la radio ou à la télé les
journaux tout le monde à l'autre oeil
mais oui ce matin chez lui au pressing
m'attends à tout moment pas à l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu trois
camps en ligne l'aventuré en parler
aussi mieux si l'on parle lui aussi fils
en parle ça veut dire que tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez l'équipe facile on est
inquiet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais sortez richie réussi cette
opération de chirurgie esthétique je
voudrais remercier féliciter le
chirurgien le professeur shauna de la
clinique azoulay
abordant à casablanca n'ont pas cédé bon
cela et voilà
messieurs
ben ça bien
j'accueille maintenant le phénomène le
plus fort dans le monde du comics depuis
coluche jamel debbouze ici
ici ici
[Musique]
ou là ça va très bien oui
jean moulin c'est alors si vous les
trucs qu'on me dit qu'un ministre est
passé si tu vas voir tu vas voir tu vas
acheter à dire quand même à toutes les
téléspectatrices qu'edel est plus beau
en vrai qu'à la télé moi j'ai toujours
vu à la télé voilà donc
et à une ouverture là et merde quoi
encore une tu savais pas j'avais la cote
avec toi
merci beaucoup en tout cas de ce
compliment ça me touche
happart jamais nous recevons ce soir
charles millon
axelle red
patrick sabatier
christine héraud
à l'été vous savez de tradition à la
télé quand on commence une nouvelle
édition la télé c'est une grande famille
on se les télégrammes alors c'est un
télégramme de le premier de christophe
dechavanne thierrée bonne chance merci
christophe
un télégramme de paco rabanne thierry
linde ag prévoit la fin de cette
émission pour le 11 septembre et croyez
moi je me plante rarement laurent
ruquier le vrai laurent ruquier qui
m'écrit bas il dit thierry sincèrement
désolés de ne pas faire un an de plus
mais j'avais trop envie de faire un an
de plus toujours égal à lui-même bravo
laurent rocco siffredi
désolé de ne pas être là pour la reprise
thierry mais j'ai la tête dans le cul
et la maman de notre ami qui dit
monsieur ardisson serait-il petit de
faire un gros plan de mon fils
serge se plaît fait un gros plan de son
fils et là je voulais juste
un message personnel à faire passer je
voulais juste souhaiter un bon
anniversaire à ma soeur valérie très
bien puisqu'on avait un message
personnel moi je voudrais dire bonsoir à
la famille vidéo qui regarde et que
j'embrasse vous avez un message
personnel d'une date ans conduisait je
te fais un gros bisou une permanence
voilà et mon frère sylvain
je vous serai là elle a deux hommes dans
sa vie c'est son frère et son père la
personne n'est parfait voilà donc tout
ça pour dire que si quelqu'un se sent le
courage oui elle est formidable c'est
agréable
ben justement assez violent pour un
télégramme pour vous linda un télégramme
de sophie thalmann miss france elle
aussi un qui dit cheikh linda comment tu
as fait pour entrer à la télé sans
coucher
un jeu j'ai couché
il
n'en parlera pas mettre un télégramme de
jacques martin que nous saluons
méfie-toi de michel drucker d'accord un
télégramme de lara fabian je t'aime je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je
t'aime merci merci l'art intégrante de
smaïn il déchire thierry merci encore de
faire de la pub pour jamel sympa une
chamelle j'ai vu peut-être intéressé aux
samplers venir voir ça tombe bien
expliquer à tous bords noirs exemple je
donne un exemple imaginons que je dise
une grosse connerie alors y'a michèle
cotta qui disent à paris je t'aime bien
mais là tu exagères voilà ça c'est la
patronne par exemple si tu racontes vous
racontez vous dit pas la vérité
[Musique]
je cite si thierry à draguer une fille
comme ça lui arrive
assez souvent
c'est pour vous
[Musique]
annoncer le premier à jouer le premier
le nouveau wali fier si j'ai bien
compris c'est pour c'est pour combler le
vide en savaient pas où me blesse c'est
quand tu galères un peu jeudi par
exemple la télé dans l'émission ça c'est
triste de l'esthète de donner ça
[Musique]
françois
taton paribas ça cib va bientôt gagner
la série on peut
la deuxième nouveauté de la saison donc
jamais elle vous êtes aperçu c'est linda
l'on pouvait jouer avec le sampler et
j'ai joué avec linda ya pas de problème
d'accords devient si tout se passe bien
alors jamel debbouze est au bataclan à
partir du 15 septembre est ce que c'est
le même spectacle créé cigale on a
repris la base du premier spectacle qui
nous paraissait pas inintéressant
tellement de succès on a retravaillé
autour et on l'a trouvé des choses un
peu fade détour il ya des nouvelles
choses bien sûr j'aurais pu répondre par
oui j'ai fait une question c'est bien
mais ça fait traiter les
l'interview vous aimez les chiens jamais
joué dans les chiens et l'alcool gère
très bien alors c'est le même metteur en
scène oui kader aoun vous pensez durer
jusqu'à noël si tout se passe bien
si tout se passe bien jusqu'à noël ouais
si linda viens pour me soutenir la bnda
enfin là on sera là leur seule personne
alors djamel on s'est connu tous les
deux il ya quand même quelques années
maintenant 35 ans qu'une lente cinq ans
bien sûr une émission que je faisais à
l'époque sur sur paris dernière sur
paris première il s'appelait paris
dernière tu as fait un méchant qui était
bien d'ailleurs je crois que c'est votre
deuxième télé la première citée pêche
d'enfer c'était la brèche était un truc
comme ça c'était tout était lé tout bleu
et par vu cette émission depuis nantes
on ne sait si vous avez les images se
voit bien pourquoi c'est pas bien
toujours à la télé on invite des gens
leur manque des images qui les met mal à
l'aise ses arches il te plait magnéto
[Musique]
récemment le ps temps
je dois répéter un marmaille là je suis
à si tu me prends la tête
journalistes tous les jeunes toute
manière ils arrivent ils arrêtent là
avec leurs seins leur technique leur
marathon se bricole leurs questions
c'est à la fin j'ai croisé journalistes
avec blizzard voit des gens heureux si
genre sournois toi genre si genre tu
sens bizarre quand genre terrorisme gens
reconnus appareil ce prix la russie
commence à me poser des questions sur le
toit était si petite île bizard qui gît
par 8 immeubles était bien habillé de
soin de moi je vais pas je traitais
artistes et chauny comme ça comme celle
là il a fait comme ça écoute bon
look si j'avais moi aussi je suis votre
quote part je suis la banlieue comme
vous ainsi ben thamer
j'ai pas par quatre chemins je vais plus
à contourner la question je vais vous
parler en toute franchise de vos
problèmes économiques sociaux culturels
car je sais ce paquet de mesures que
vous avez d'énormes problèmes vous
insérez parmi les gens normaux
je sais que votre père tapotement que
vous en est réduit à vous servir de
crédit comme moyen de locomotion sur
tout va que c'est pas vrai j'ai des
preuves si ça marche aussi grave j'étais
binaire graves comme lui est tout sauf
grave tout à l'heure après j'ai regardé
jeudi le brontosaure le brontosaure
d'abord duch on vous voit
on a joué on n'a jamais voulu d'un cas
l'ensemble qu'ils sachent d'accord a
donc tu vois d'abord du jeudi je me
demande quelle est celle où les deux
qu'elle puisse de mal à s'insérer par
les gendarmes en
moi avec mes caddie ou lui avec sa plume
sur la tête là nous deux c'est pas mon
père qui tape ma mère c'est ma mère
carte mon père
dernière
c'était
serré quand j'étais en cm2 ça ouais
ouais c'était que c'était il ya très
très longtemps je me souviens de cette
disparition non sérieusement ça vous
embête de non non pas du tout non mais
c'est à la télé moi où je me regarde pas
j'ai toujours un peu crédible sur ce que
je fais j'ai fait les choses et souvent
je ne trouve pas bien après et là je
trouve ça provient du tout un bon ballon
de chanel à ce qu'on vienne barre donc
c'était la deuxième télé après on pas
raconter votre carrière parce qu'elle a
été racontée en long et en large et une
ovale paris première une autre émission
qui était une émission nova sur paris
première il ya eu il ya eu h
npa
le cinéma avec son 11e et puis le ciel
les oiseaux et ta mère qui fait quand
même dix mille 1 million par an 10
millions d'hommes ayant 10 millions
d'indiens il ya un million de millions
mais mnp à canal+ c'est c1 halabi un
alibi pour vous celle inverse c'est une
des fonds j'ai vu dans les interviews de
vous demander souvent est ce que vous
pensez pas être l'alibi de canal+ moi
j'ai plutôt l'impression finalement
c'est canal+ que votre alibi pour
regrouper durant combien deschanel plus
uniquement et simplement pour l'argent
faut pas l'oublier et les meufs et celle
d'argent ça a marché non mais mes
sources bon point pour atteindre plus
sérieux on m'a souvent posé la question
il ne faut pas que tu es là tel a été le
quota de canal + se prête à un robot de
canal+
je pense vraiment pas je pense que alain
de greef m'a engagé parce qu'il croyait
en moi j'espère enfin je suis sûre même
puisque je le dis comme ça mais c'est un
échange de bons procédés finalement oui
de toute manière comme dans une comme
dans toute association qui fonctionne
bien tu vois
gj gagner et aussi mais c'est sûr qu'au
début on pouvait se poser la question et
enfin continent et en fin de compte
je
gère
[Musique]
ça veut dire à chaque fois qu'il va
pêcher un bouton vous aller applaudir
comme des imbéciles là j'ai compris le
système
obtiendriez une punition aussi dans le
sampler si par exemple j'étais un truc
vraiment ou moi ou linda dit un truc
vraiment pénible à la punition mesdames
messieurs 6
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
c'est i muvrini voilà moi j'ai pas
interdire en corse parce que tu vois non
mais mais alors chaque fois que je dire
une connerie ira ça ira ça ouais et
quand tu es quand tu dis un truc génial
rsa
bon alors la gloire vous parlez beaucoup
de votre gloire
la mercedes tapis rouge aux bains
douches excusé et j'en parle pas moi
sans les gens disent on fait parler oui
mais vous avez quand même il ya un truc
plus intéressant si vous avez quand même
une méfiance paris vous appelez ça le
côté obscur c'est quand même une
méfiance de paris ouvrait un le que ces
messages et j'habite à part à trappes
dans les yvelines et on débarque d'un
besoin dans une jungle véritablement je
suis pas là à faire tu sais très bien
comment ça se passe thierry faible à ton
petit malin mais je sais
mais mais mais ouais j'ai tout était
inaccessible et d'un coup tout s'ouvre
donc forcément tu te méfier tu prend de
la distance avec les filles ça se passe
bien maintenant un peu mieux un peu
mieux mais je galère encore vraiment
c'est vrai
[Musique]
alors comme ça tombe il faut que
j'arrête parce que sinon j'ai passé la
soirée avec sa mère si si aujourd'hui
une fille une jeune femme que vous avez
draguer ya cinq ans et qui vous avez
jeté drague à son tour aujourd'hui je la
jette plus aucun intérêt non non il faut
passer maintenant je passe à autre chose
maintenant annoncé cesser linda que juif
non mais il
[Musique]
ya quelque chose qu'il ya une chose que
je prends à ta question oui effecté
comment les filles intéressées non mais
je sais pas si je détecte et filles
intéressées moi je suis sincèrement je
suis très naïve de ce côté là je ne
crois pas qu'on détecte et quoi que ce
soit grâce
à moi je fonctionne à la blague à part
mais j'ai aimé c'est vrai que que non
non j'ai pas jamais toujours à trappes
j'ai pas bougé je rencontre les filles
avec qui chante gérer calmement et
semblent souvent à trappes j'habite
encore là bas niveau tous les soirs soir
ont trouvé celui ans plus tard pour
partie forcément alors il ya une phrase
moi de vous déjà mais ce que je trouve
très très bien c'est quand vous parlez
de paris vous dites c'est comme dans le
film quand charlton heston
descend du mont sinaï où il a reçu les
dix commandements vous dit à moïse un
bruit de charlton heston quand ce qui
est très symbolique quand il a reçu les
dix commandements il descend comme ça du
il descend du sinaï voit tous les
hébreux en train d'adorer le veau d'or
et ça c'est un peu l'image que vous
faites de paris finalement ben ouais
parce que
c'est sincèrement j'arrive là depuis
deux trois ans dans un univers que je
connaissais pas c'est à dire on se
faisait dans calais matin midi et soir
de toutes les bois que vous toutes les
boîtes que j'ai fait sans exception sans
exception je vous dis je me faisais
recalé en bloc tout papa toutes les
filles sans exception mais on avait du
mal avec les filles aussi pareil on
n'avait pas l'argent qu'il fallait pour
avoir les sabres qu'il fallait on
n'était pas dans le coup donc ont été
mis à l'écart et est maintenant d'un
coup tout le monde s'intéresse à moi et
tout le monde fait attention à ce que je
dis c'est formidable
alors jamais on va maintenant finir un
petit peu cette parce qu'après on va
passer une vrai interview on va on va
finir un peu avec un extrait moi qui m'a
beaucoup plus c'est quand vous étiez à
cannes c'est d'ailleurs comme l'émission
paris dernière réalisée par sylvain
bergère c'est le journal de la nuit et
on vous voit face à face avec le plus
grand comique français laurent gerra
magnéto serge si le peuple est
avec un super bowl
ban ont
profité il y avait la mine
des plus grands tubes annoncé
sur canal + sur cette drôle
effectivement on arrive à être parfaite
valère
[Rires]
audy nous qu'est-ce qui va croire ce que
j'ai c'est qu'on peut pas bouffer 5e
caméra
[Rires]
à lérida corps
le cadre est serré
avec un décor à denis
bouffard une mutation de gène et vidéo
par le nom
avait
comme en face à fait vrai enfin grand
passer l'eau
doit se demander
non magistrats dire qu'il était le mec
là des mecs les plus drôles de france
voilà ça c'est vrai
c'est de la chance en plus d'être bien
accompagné
il vient il dit dans des endroits sont
que
la casse mais après tout le monde
circule
works est l'homme le plus grand de
france
on enchaîne avec un pieu alors donc vous
avez comme je disais tout à l'heure vous
avez beaucoup raconté votre légende vous
avez un discours très au point
d'ailleurs qu'on voit à la télé ou quand
on voit ton livre déclarations dans la
presse discours très haut point c'est
parce qu'on pose tout autant les mêmes
caisses voilà c'est justement ce qu'on
va pas ce que vous dites que vous avez
un personnage très très construit vous
dit évidemment mon personnage est
construite toute pièce parce que si
j'étais comme lui j'aurai une chambre à
sainte anne depuis depuis longtemps bien
évidemment bien évidemment alors vous
posez des questions qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de vous poser la télé à ça ça
fait plaisir par contre voilà quoi nous
laisser un peu la lumière mais
[Musique]
j'aime pas les cracks marques comme ça
est-ce que je peux avoir un canif au
couteau suisse est possible ou pas à
régis bande d'enfoirés vous êtes tous
avec lui dans là d'une question simple à
vous pensez à quoi là maintenant tout de
suite tout de suite c'est non mais
franchement un mois c'est vulgaire non
mais tu
n'en as pas rapper avec pas le vide à ce
que mon nom mais c'est bon on peut se
lâcher un peu plus nous mêmes non non
non je te jure bon
je rigole je suis là comme ça je me
demande ce que tu as posé comme question
bon ben voilà donc qu'est ce que tu
penses ce matin quand tu te fais dans la
glace quand tu travailles la première
chose que tu te dis quant à vous vous
dites pardon quand vous je me dis
si je faisais dix centimètres de plus
chez un mannequin
c'est pas impossible dix centimètres de
plus bon je serai comme ça quand vous
étiez petit voulait ressembler à qui
quand j'étais petit je voulais
ressembler à tony montana dans scarface
s'est excusé moi ça vu le film scarface
ouais bien sûr je vous laisse lui comme
plein de mecs dans le quartier ce qui
nous énerve le plus chez vous ce que je
supporte pas que c'est difficile icd
essayons d'avoir cette question bah
ouais mon moment que deux de ces des
subjectivités je pense ouais j'aime pas
ma subjectivité trouve qu'elle est
passée adéquat
que des mots compliqués la cité où là
j'avais du cabinet est-ce que vous
supportez pas chez moi qu'est-ce que
vous supportez pas chez moi thierry
dusautoir pourquoi tu t'habilles tout en
noir pour être sûr tant me reconnaissent
et me dit c'est pas pour ça arrête de me
dire que c'est pourquoi pas on tire
comme ça ce que ça marche c'est parce
que ça même si
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça m'a si oui alors c'est
pas un gros là bas non non non on fait
du sport depuis quelques temps ben j'ai
un côté sama le noir ça m'a simba le
noir c'est merci oui bien sûr la preuve
qu'est-ce que vous supportez pas chez
linda ouais j'ai vraiment pour l'instant
rien du tout
je supporte tout pour le moment et comme
dirait quand vous êtes vous senti le
maître du monde est ce qu'un jour vous
avez eu le sentiment d'être vraiment un
demi-dieu de en toute modestie jamais
ouais non je te jure que jamais et
aujourd'hui ce qu' il ya quelque chose
que vous soyez à voir absolument que
voudriez par dessus tout vous ne pouvez
pas acheter
qui vous tenterait ou qui vous ferait
extrêmement plaisir et que vous pouvez
pas posséder
la conduite comme ça mais mise à part
toilettage voit pas
mais non non quelle insulte qui vous a
fait le plus mal en fait dans votre vie
espèce de sale arabe
enfin que m'a fait le plus mal c'est des
trucs tu supportes pas du tout que
j'entends de moins en moins maintenant
mais
de jure mais mais mais c'est vraiment il
part relevant entendre et quand vous
écrivez eu l'autographe vous écrivez
ça dépend si c'est des filles ou des
garçons de 6 et une fille je marque gros
bisous jamais de nous y fait un coeur si
c'est un garçon je marque je dégage
dégage
est ce que j'ai déjà sorti avec la
copine un copain pour voir si vous avez
un peu de moral quand même oui je veux
tu écris dans le plat c'est d'actualité
merde merde serait alors pas du tout
jamais je vais avec le copain ou une
copine avec le copain d'une copie d'un
plugin non encore moins bon si par
exemple vous trouvez un porte monnaie
avec 500 francs dedans par terre vous
fait quoi maintenant je leur en avons
voulu garder ouais c'est honnête j'ai eu
mal aux jambes moi je laurent parce que
je pense à la pauvre vieille exemple
j'étais en turquie et je trouve et
s'était hissé tgt j'avais pas encore
autant d'argent qu'aujourd'hui
et je trouve un portefeuille mais super
blindé d'argent plein et épais tousser
et c'était une demoiselle qui étaient là
kik et qui travaillait dans l'hôtel où
j'étais j'ai elle va elle vendait des
pellicules je me rappelle je prends le
portage il jure en jurant pas jure en
jurant pareil je rentre je rends pas
duran duran pas j'y allais à les juger
en jeu lui arriver juin et je fais la
queue pour lui rendre sur la queue pour
lui rendre est un moment donné je te
jure juge alors j'arrive jurant le
portefeuille et puis je lui dit excusez
moi je pourrais avoir cette pellicule
demi tube over la clope qui me
regardent comme s'agit mais pourquoi par
dell de merde jours-ci de colas là
dessus ça m'a énervé qu'est ce que vous
seriez prêt à tout quitter pour le grand
amour
ça ça se discute cellule bon ça c'est
parce que tu peux rien faire d'autre
moitié je peux pas être me pombieilh
mécaniciens ne pas me lever à 8 heures
du matin il finira 17 heures mais pour
elle
peut-être ah si vraiment c'est le grand
amour un grand amour grand grand amour
je lâche tout
donc le grand amour né n'est pas encore
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
djamel un héros un rôle de jamal un
héros est ce que si vous étiez ruiné
plus du tout d'argent enfin vraiment peu
une étude est ce que vous seriez prêt à
tourner dans un film porno ont
aucune chance pour un truc très simple
jamais je serai je serai ruine et j'ai
dit tiens on a une famille assez
solidaires et dès qu'il ya un problème
ils sont là serait jamais obligé je suis
né je pense est-ce que vous préféreriez
faire l'amour avec une fille très laide
ou un mec très beau
produit quelques questions
mais que ouais c'est ça faut pas arrêter
comment
des questions à leurs symptômes qui
écrit les questions quand il est fait
sur le contrôle et les questions comme
ça si tu veux les faux-pas info prendre
dit doliprane
parce qu'il ya eu la douleur fausse
tenter la douleur d'avoir fait prendre à
moi c'est bien ça stoppe la douleur et
quelques clics et tu préfère faire la
une on ne sait où l'homosexualité ou une
fuite khaled par an soit une fille très
laide ou un mec très beau vous
choisiriez quoi j'irai plus vers la
savonnette mois
et entre une miss monde et trois miss
france vous prenez quoi je pense je
prends trois miss france 3000 francs en
argentine c'est gentil pour les diamants
33 miss france si vous aviez 24 heures
avis vous feriez quoi on vous dit vous
allez mourir dans 24 heures foyer quoi
je vais auprès de pierre bleue tout ce
que tu veux mais c'est la vérité je vais
auprès de maman ouais je reste avec l 24
heures ils attendent comme ça je le sais
voulu monter jamais à votre maman non
c'est l'une des rares personnes à qui je
mens pas pourquoi parce que le sait tout
de suite quand je monte parce que je
fais des petits quand je mangeais à
chaque ligne un peu maintenant je dois
je vais y travailler
ah ouais fin de ma gueule
arie un truc chez vous qui étiez très
étonnant parce que aujourd'hui dans les
la télé à la radio les gens osent plus
dire qu'ils sont croyants catholiques
c'est un peu passé de mode c'est un peu
ringard c'est des gens comme vous et
c'est des gens comme vous qui osez dire
finalement beaucoup plus que les
catholiques ben moi je suis musulman je
suis croyant également je fais un petit
peu d c'est d'autant plus difficile
qu'en ce moment on n'a pas trop la cote
de ce côté là les intégristes ne font
pas une super bonne publicité non plus
hein nous non plus les cathos les
intégrés s'ils nous font pas une bonne
oui on mais mais mais mais on parle un
peu plus de nous que vous en ce moment
excuse moi
mais c'est vrai que non j'ai aucun
problème avec ça j'ai été baigné là
dedans mes parents moi mon mot élevé
avec avec ses
traditions là je suis musulman je
l'assumé mais c'est un truc que je vais
très bien parce que l'islam est une
religion qui est très très tolérant très
ouverte et et je la kiffe je trouve que
c'est très c'est là c'est la classe des
musulmans est ce que vous buvez pas vous
fumez pas non je vois pas je fume pas
c'est sérieux et on vous pratiquez les
cinq prières par jour par exemple
j'essaye du mieux que je peux mais comme
je rentre tard des fois c'est bien là
c'était quand la dernière la cgt mois de
novembre dernier
un vrai dans leurs prières dans la lah
c'était ce matin ah oui donc 5 c'était
entre 8 et 9,9 et 5,1 ce matin je me
suis levé et est 10 heures et tu sais il
ya des heures précises avec elf au sort
hier il je demande la dernière à la
dernière c'était ce matin alors j'en ai
encore quatre à rattraper
c'est bien ce que
m'a l'air d'être très très vif
carneiro quoi moi ouais je viens courbet
à l'eau non au nom si je devrais être en
interne leurs quatre shows ce sera
endigué par un guépard c'est bien que
j'aie pas c'est bien si la mcl avec
classe le guépard dans la savane front
il est bien habillé le guépard il ya des
beaux habits est-ce que vous avez menti
depuis le début de cette émission n'ont
franchement pas dépendre ce jour non pas
encore mais c'est bien je suis ravie
merci c'était l'odeur des lumières
[Applaudissements]
avant avant de passer à notre invitation
mais bien entendu vous restez avec nous
je voudrais pardon vous lisez le
chocolat ça moi je voulais dire que j'ai
des regrets l'ont surpris par ce genre
de question parce que je suis pas
l'habitude comme les pauses mais voilà
c'est bien thierry cain d'aiguillon
[Musique]
alors avant j'étais un mec bien je me
comprends
avant de passer à notre invité suivant
bien entendu bien sûr djamel vous restez
avec nous j'ai la vitesse du vent
charles millon challenge me bat
mais on va regarder on va en garde le
moral c'est facile on a fait ce monsieur
discutera revient en tâtant oui il
arrive mais avant avant charles millon
je voudrais quand on regarde un extrait
du spectacle jamel en scène donc à la
cigale et qu'on va retrouver à partir du
15 septembre au bataclan magnéto serge
noms des six candidats qui vont bien à
reste quand même maintenant
[Applaudissements]
as dû pleurer
avec des job les gars gagnent elles
ça m'a préparé on peut discuter on peut
discuter quand même c'est pas ce matin
j'étais enchanté c'est pas chanter ses
tubes d'innocence avant
lundi matin le prince ahmed
sow demi chez moi pour que les pompes
der un petit truc
comme visiter pas chez moi le petit
prince a dit ah bon il pas chez lui et
c'est pas grave je vais revenir plus dur
dur demain mardi matin que classe sa
mère le prince et puis sa mère
[Musique]
sont venus chez moi pour pourtant vapeur
à
comme cité des jarres et félin foot les
petits princes a dit ah bon agent
recueillera foot c'est pas grave encore
du vin je veux revenir du royaume à
battre du matin le prince sa mère
sa tante avec se connaît pas
et puis à notre mec sans venu chez moi
pour que je le leur a gentiment des
prêts était
et comme je vais gaspiller tout
l'appartement d'ébriété le petit prince
a dit abonnés dispute on devait me
prêter
à partir du 15 septembre au bataclan
salle de la cigale c'était bourré d'une
étoile ouais hein abdullah comme on dit
chez moi c'était plein mais mais mais le
bataclan cccc un autre part il ya
beaucoup plus sur quatre mois et on
attend 80 mille personnes ah ouais donc
je vous en supplie venez tôt mais on
sera là non sera parmi les 80 merci très
bien j'accueille maintenant notre asile
à suivre ans jamais le doigt et c'est
avec tout charles millon
[Musique]
3 millions en soir on soit connaissait
djamel vous connaissez mardi on soit
charles millon champmillon merci d'être
avec nous parce que c'est vrai que c'est
une émission je dis pas difficile parce
qu on est vachement sympa mais enfin
c'est vrai que c'est une émission où là
où la liberté de ton et peut-être un peu
plus grande qu'ailleurs alors jean mimi
on va faire un petit un petit come on
rex était prêté latif vois ça c'est bien
ça
donc il yal'affaire millions on va en
parler puis après on parlera de l'avenir
on va pas rester scotchés là dessus tout
la soirée vous étiez un homme politique
disons centre-droit plutôt fréquentable
vous avez été ministre de la défense
entre 95 et 97
sous chirac bien entendu vous étiez
prodi solution assez ça vous étiez pour
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
oui avec changement premier ministre
avec changement de premier ministre et
le 20 mars 1998 êtes élu président de la
région rhône alpes avec les voix des
conseillers du front national d'ailleurs
il ya eu un moment il ya eu un fameux
vendredi a eu un moment où tout a failli
basculer
c'est effectivement le jour où beaucoup
de régions en france beaucoup de
présidents de région ont été élus avec
les voix du front national et madelin a
dit d'ailleurs en parlant de ce fameux
vendredi plus rien ne sera jamais comme
avant et puis on peut penser que jean
marie le pen en exigeant la présidence
de paca a fait échouer la faire on peut
se demander s'il n'était pas lié comme
on l'a dit souvent
l'allié objectif disons de la gauche
donc vous vous avez été à partir de là
entre guillemets le président élu grâce
au fn donc ça vous est resté comme ça
collait je disais j'avais un jet à un
projet politique j'ai présenté mon
projet politique il ya un certain nombre
de voix qui se sont portées sur ce point
j'ai c'est pas parce que les bois vient
d'ici ou de là qu'on va en fait remettre
en cause le projet qui avait obtenu le
soutien de la majorité des rhônalpins
j'avais lorsqu'un communiste dit le
soleil brille et que effectivement le
soleil brille ce n'est pas parce que je
suis pas d'accord avec lui que je veux
dire qu'il pleut lorsque quelqu'un du
front national dit il pleut et que
effectivement il pleut c'est pas parce
qu'il est du front national que je vais
dire qu'il fait beaucoup dit quand on
est élu on est élu peu importe d'où
vient d'où viennent les voies alors en
même temps c'était pas seulement un
hasard c'est une stratégie parce que
vous dites le front national est légal
l'état de chaque année 41 millions de
francs au front national donc c'est un
parti légal il n'y a pas de raison s'il
est légal on ne s'associe pas avec lui
votre après tout françois mitterrand
avait bien
fait la même chose avec le pcf dans
l'union de la gauche ce que vous vouliez
votre stratégie c'était de briser le
tabou y c'était ça c'était de sortir
sortir de la tenaille et vous avez dit à
l'époque si j'arrive à intégrer le front
national dans la vie politique française
j'aurais rendu un fier service à la
france c'est pas tout j'étais voulu je
les regrette pas du tout ce n'est pas
tout à fait cela que j'ai dit j'ai dit
la chose suivante
[Musique]
j'ai dit la chose suivante il y a deux
méthodes de faire la politique soit vous
la faites après vous êtes fait élire
alors besoin des alliances avec untel ou
untel c'est à dire que vous faites votre
petite cuisine dans votre petit but
votre petite casserole sur votre petit
fourneau dans votre petit coin c'est ce
qu'une expression du général de gaulle
ou alors vous avez une autre solution si
vous présenter un projet puis quand les
gens à adopter ce projet bien vous le
mettez en oeuvre la première solution
c'est une solution de tromperie et la
deuxième solution c'est une solution de
clarté donc voila voila j'ai un petit
peu brossé le tableau l'histoire
l'historique de la faire parce que tout
le monde n'a pas ça obligatoirement
toujours en tête moi j'ai une question à
vous poser en fait est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous pensez que vous avez fait une
boulette une grosse connerie ou est ce
que vous le regrettez donc en
l'occurrence ou est-ce que vous pensez
que vous aviez raison voilà c'est la
seule question finalement enfin pas la
seule mais c'est la question principale
que j'ai envie de vous poser le doigt
sur le bouton puis vous mettez je ne
regrette rien ah on la passe un drop
l'attend on a pas on est désolés
vous avez pas répondu à la question non
je ne regrette rien donc vous ne
regrettez pas du tout vous dit pas
aujourd'hui j'ai fait une erreur
j'aurais pas dû faire ça comme ça parce
que c'est on peut faire des erreurs
marketing et regardez là la smart c'est
une
tout alors je ne reviens très bien je si
j'avais arrêté quelque chose j'aurais
démissionné on ne s'était pas une
connerie je regrette pas je suis mme ce
que j'ai fais très bien mais dès le
début quand même et pas seulement la
gauche puisque chirac vous a dit j'ai
téléphoné pour vous dire charles taffs
et nicole chirac porte et qui lui dit
qu'il est dit charles tu as fait une
connerie raymond barre qui a toujours
été votre mentor en politique dans la
région n'étaient pas solidaires
donc je dirai ce que je veux dire
champions c'est qu'ils avaient pas
seulement la gauche et qui qui qui
étaient contre ça avait aussi des gens
de votre de votre bord des gens de la
droite non comme c'est ce qu'on appelle
le politiquement correct c'est à dire
que bernard dunne je pose des questions
et met dans le vent
après tu c'est de ma faute alors là
jamel
richardson
connaît à peine le politiquement correct
c'est à dire que vous avez un certain
nombre de personnages politiques
quel que soit le poste qu'ils occupent
qui n'osent pas aller contre des tabous
une pensée conforme à partir de là vous
avez été diabolisé ostracisé vous êtes
devenu un peu le paria de la classe
politique et des moments difficiles qu'a
été le moment le plus difficile ce que
le monument à la mémoire des enfants
juifs à lisieux où on vous a interdit de
nous approcher tout à fait sans doute le
moment qui était le plus émouvant est le
plus triste parce que j'ai consacré une
bonne part de ma vie à cette cause de ma
vie politique je me suis investi oui je
suis très triste et si vous avez créé ce
parti qui s'appelle la droite de la
droite c'est quand même qu'en france
c'est un gros mot depuis quarante-quatre
la droite gérard 44 depuis 1789 puisque
vous n'avez la droite tu dis à quelqu'un
à qui on dit allez on y va te faire
droite et
non mais je sais pas quand on dit la
droite en france on les gens entendent
tout de suite
vichysme voir nazisme enfin la droite
depuis quarante gares depuis la droite a
perdu la guerre on pourrait dire même
déjà en 47 quand encore les deux
golfeuses et de l'affichage pour son
parti qui s'appelait le rpf à l'époque
déjà il y avait des gens qu'ils aient
des croix gammées sur les affiches de
nos vols donc je veux dire la droite
c'est la provocation d'appeler un parti
la droite la droite c'est complexe et
elle n'a pas voulu porter les valeurs
auxquelles elle croit qu'ils sont là
valeurs de liberté d'autonomie de
responsabilité d'initiative des valeurs
telles que les valeurs familiales ou les
valeurs entrepreneuriales
lc complexé pas ce qu'on lui disait si
tu te dit de droite tu es un pétainiste
tué à fasciste je ne suis ni pessimiste
ni fasciste je suis de droite je suis
fidèle à des valeurs auxquelles les gens
tiennent cois lorsque moi je vais dans
ma circonscription
tous les gens pas tout cela parce que je
respecte tous ceux qui sont à gauche
voulait dire et bien là il faut que la
droite
n'ont
pas trop justement c'est vrai on en
parle à tous à faire de la casse c'est
vrai avec quelqu'un qui va venir nous
voir mais c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas
on peut venir d une grande conscience
politique parce que j'y parle plutôt du
nutella
elle parle toujours de mythe est là mais
il ya quand même quelque chose derrière
arrêter les conneries merde
quand je dis quand je dis je je je ne
suis pas la politique c'est parce qu'il
m'intéresse pas au sepa sepa pour vous
je dis ça mais j'ai jamais connue depuis
que je suis en âge de comprendre un
homme politique qui a tenu ses
engagements jusqu'au bout et qui m'a
prouvé que ce qu'ils disaient c'était
vrai que il pourrait changer les choses
non pensez quoi de gmail quand par
exemple sur le million et contre le vote
des immigrés trouve ça regrettable pour
tout l'été comme quand il est pour la
peine de mort ou comme quand il est peu
contre l'avortement ou comme quand il
est pour le pacs trouve ça dommage ce
genre de raid de choses mais chacun sa
vie en tout cas jamais la politique
c'est le débat oui mais bien mais qu'est
ce que j'ai dit gilles contraire j'ai
juste dit que pose la question je n'ai
pas que je me sens capable mais je vais
gens je crois qu'on peut on peut
débattre d'un certain nombre de
vous êtes ont à peine de mort
véritablement où c'est pour heures je
suis pas pour la peine de mort je veux
tu es contre l'abolition de la peine de
mort parce qu'à l'époque il n'y avait
pas de peines de substitution
je dis qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
problème est toujours posée parce qu'en
fermé quelqu'un pour 18 ans pour 20 ans
ou même au delà c'est l'enfermer dans
l'enfer et donc il faut que tu ne sais
pas du tout ce serait fou de jouer ça
sent la notation se videra il a galéré
il fait rien de spécial pour moi non il
faut le mettre alors qu'il y en a
d'autres je pense qu'il ya une réflexion
à mener en matière pénitentiaire pour
savoir s'il n'est pas meilleur de lise
les dans un cas quand vous vous dites
fois que tu es direct non j'ai pas du
tout vous avez dit ça tout allait jamais
d'exiger des témoins ils sont deux
j'entendais mal ramé pour blague à part
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort je
suis pour une antenne si de substitution
qui soit applicable qu'ils soient
humaines aujourd'hui la peine de
substitution comme ami elle est
inhumaine car enfermer quelqu'un dans
une pièce de 4 mètres sur 4 durant 18 20
ans 22 ans 25 ans le type il devient fou
devient une loque d'accord et que dans
ce cas là il vaut peut-être mieux
chercher d'autres notes d'isolement
social c'est à dire qu on peut trouver
il existe et je vais vous dire un mot
qui va vous choquer puisque puisqu'on
fait une émission plus choquant si
politiquement incorrect envahie à
l'émission peut dire l'extrême le bagne
le bagne est meilleur que la prison à
vie car au moins vous êtes vous pouvez
avoir une activité et qu'on peut faire
un bagne moderne où les gens sont bannis
parce qu'on les met en dehors de la
société pour pas qu'ils portent atteinte
aux autres qu'ils ne violent pas qu'il
ne tue pas qu'ils n'atteignent pas la
liberté des autres mais au moins on leur
laisse une ère d'expansion et de liberté
d'épanouissement isolé de la société que
je pense que le grand problème c'est que
voyez je viens d'utiliser un mot je suis
sûr que demain on va lire charles
million 1 point le bagne j'ai pas dit du
tout méchant dans tous les cas vous
voyez la force des mots parce que vous
souvenez que quand edouard balladur
avait dit on devrait discuter de la
préférence nationale qui existe dans un
tas de pays dans le monde s'est fait un
scandale bien là la force des monts tout
à fait blanc vous saviez ça que la
gauche et l arbitre des élégances en
france même même alain madelin
aujourd'hui dit qu'il faut fumer des
pétards
non mr damas direct à toxicomanes
programme
aussi non
vous allez au massacre la tête mais je
pense que les choses changent ouais
parce que le 17 heures déléguera
boutique du pollen 10 00
c'est mort elle n'a jamais jamais jamais
fumé thiam était jamais techi j'ai
jamais joué et des deux labels de
l'herbe
non je vais
pas vous avez encore le temps sur l'art
et oui encore attendre quoi est-ce que
ça je suis sûr que vous avez fumé de la
brp pas pourquoi vous avez une cave
enfumée de labeur ont en conséquence
mais bon ce soir
[Applaudissements]
est ce que je gagnais bouquin de jean
d'ormesson il fait état d'une confidence
que françois mitterrand lui aurait
faites concernant le lobby juif est le
fils de françois mitterrand on a rajouté
une couche encore plus épaisse derrière
est ce que vous vous croyez qu'il ya un
lobby juif en france je pense que les
groupes d'influencé est évident il ya un
groupe d'influents ce juif et un groupe
d'influencé catholique et un groupe
d'influents ce protestant qu'il ya eu le
groupe d' influence des parents d'élèves
le groupe d'influencé industriels et que
ça me paraît douteux couple influence
des amis de jamel debbouze de trappes
ça me parait il paraît tout à fait
naturel et normal donc l'expression le
billet est une expression qui a en
france choc entre cette chance aux états
unis à l'oeil gauche demande est
reconnue namuroise unis les biens en
france très bien que ça évoque quand
même des choses qui sont pas très donc
c'est pour ça que je me paraîtrait plus
intelligent et plus judicieux d'utiliser
le terme groupes d'influencé groupes
d'influencé l'accord est tout à fait
normal alors dernière chose puis je vous
laisserai dans les
jamais il répond à ce qu'on leur propose
dessus comme ça j'aurai mais j'ai pas
pour vous uniquement chargé pour un non
mais c'est vrai tu poses une question
l'étudient alors oui qu'est ce qu'ils
ont mangé hier je vous explique ce n'est
pas la question qu'il faut poser
exactement et vos boutons savoir qui est
le cuistot
ou quand des idées oui non oui non
charles millon plus grave là maintenant
vous jouer un peu les t-bonds l'honnête
rustique provincial machin et et voilà
mais quand même et ça rejoint un petit
peu ce que vient de dire jamel en 1992
dans le point
vous avez déclaré à catherine pégard l'
alliance avec le fn est une
collaboration dessus alors ça c'est sa
voile alors là ça lui donne je dirais ça
donne raison au fait qu'il y ait des
hommes politiques comme ça parce que
vous dites en 92 alliance avec le fn et
une collaboration et puis en 98
finalement
on accepte tout à fait votre explication
mais enfin vous gouverner la région avec
les voix du fn c'est pas une
collaboration ça sert à rien à voir a
expliqué nous allons très bien
comprendre on attend que tout s'explique
on attend une alliance c'est quoi ces
deux personnes qui se mettent ensemble
qui se font des concessions les unes les
autres qui dit je te donne ça tu me
prends ça et qui après dix ans va gérer
ensemble
l'autre solution c'est une personne qui
arrive qui dit voilà quelles sont les
actions que j'ai engagées
qui veut les soutenir sans ce compromis
sans concession sans discussion je ne
change rien à mon projet et à ce moment
là il ya une majorité qui dit ok je
soutiens ce projet dans le premier cas
vous savez des compromis et vous avez un
renoncement à vos valeurs dans le second
cas vous restez à bout fidèle à nos
valeurs et vous ne changez aller à votre
comportement vous jamais longtemps je
m'y connais pas aux politiques autant je
trouve c'est nice qui se vit dont
l'origine remonte le coup ensemble et là
on est condamné ou alors tu moi je
décide du coup il si tu te mets avec moi
bâtiment donc ça veut dire que on
s'allie avec les gens qui se ressemble
s'assemble en même temps vous connaissez
ces dictons nom sali avec des personnes
qui ont les mêmes valeurs et convictions
que oui dont on parle là du fn vous avez
donc les mêmes valeurs et l'imposition
non je vous jure
il ya deux solutions petit à la première
chaîne a fait peur board pas parce que
donc on place à lardy view serge khalfon
on peut baisser un petit peu la lumière
mines d'or et là messieurs alors linda
alors moi je vais vous poser je vous ai
interviewé d'une manière un peu plus
intime j'espère que vous allez vous
prêter au jeu donc
d'abord on sait qu'en général les hommes
politiques sont grands séducteurs et qui
plaisent beaucoup aux femmes donc moi je
voudrais savoir par exemple qu'est-ce
qui fait aux yeux des femmes que vous
charles millon que vous êtes a priori
plus attirant que thierry ardisson
cannes jamel qui sont pas mal en fait
comment est ce que vous allez casser non
moi je trouve la tête à la classe avec
ta cravate de toutes les couleurs
comment est ce que vous essayez c'est
vrai que c'est en politique le pouvoir
attire les femmes lancée que le pouvoir
attire les femmes le pouvoir dire tout
le monde et en particulier les femmes
puisque affichant le pouvoir les
lumières l'argent et est ce qu ont
séduit une femme comment séduire
l'auditoire je crois oui c'est à dire le
rapport avec eux sont les mêmes noms le
rapport avec une seule est le rapport
avec une femme sont très très très
proches c'est à dire que lorsque vous
faites un discours non seulement vous
les convaincre avec des arguments mais
vous essayez de convaincre aussi avec
des sentiments avec des oui c'est à dire
que c'est la passion quoi qu'il en soit
que c'est à dire la vraie leçon de son
métier
quand vous draguer une prothèse parce
qu'on voulait tichy si tu sors avec moi
je te baisse des impôts avant
l'averse
est-ce que vous avez été déjà victime de
harcèlement sexuel de l'or ben c'est ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon on sait que vous êtes marié à
chantal delsol depuis maintenant 29 ans
parce que trente ans ça si vous n'étiez
pas marié bouton vous était tombé
amoureux d'une d'une femme politiquement
opposées à vos idées est-ce que c'est
ses propres idées et cette opposition
aura été une entrave à votre relation
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut je
mens je pense que pour pouvoir se marier
avec quelqu'un il faut avoir un même
projet de vie vous auriez jamais pu
épouser une fille du pc par exemple je
pense que j'aurais eu quelques petits
problèmes parce que l'amour non mais la
fifa elle vous plaît vous l'adorez balle
vous faites l'amour merveilleusement
avec elle et elle est du pc qu'est ce
qui se passe mais attention je l'a
convertie ah ouais d'accord vous la
trouvez retisser paul myners avait donc
vous voulez que
les dépôts vous supportez le mieux chez
votre femme
cette opacité nous sommes en tête m'en
parlez pas de la durée de votre mariage
en disant ça obligatoirement
bretonne ne valent pas breton est bon
j'imagine que comme toute âme amoureux
de sa femme vous devez être un petit peu
jaloux est ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé de fouiller dans le sac de votre
femme pour regarder son carnet d
adresses pour pouvoir téléphoner mais
après lui avoir demandé l'autorisation
et si l écouter les messages de votre
téléphone portable ça vous ferait je
trouve pas ça très élégant
ça vous ferait non je réponds parce que
je suis maintenant séparés laquelle sont
autant d'expériences et vous j'ai rien
cacher d'abord et puis je me dis je
trouve pas ça très élégant c'est tout
c'est plutôt un porte jarretelles ou
culotte petit bateau
moi je suis de
tout ce que ma femme mais ce qu'elle
plaît à se mettre adéquat
il vous permet de garder ma velouté et
elle était habillée comment l'ana fois
où vous l'avez vu
vous êtes une robe blanche à vous en
souvenez
vous de cinq ans de mariage les mecs ça
se gâte plus du tout la place ensemble
est habillé ces dernières une petite
robe blanche une robe blanche jugé qu
typique
mais chantal fait comme dira chantal que
félicitations parce qu'après 30 ans de
mariage et souvient encore de la façon
dont vous êtes habillé bravo champion
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez une femme à qui meurent y
est vous ressemblez
vous avez vous avez voto
pascal sevran
pascal sevran suggère jamel debbouze
ben je vais vous donner un petit truc
comme ça vous et aux décisions
difficiles aux mains d'un belle paire de
loches
si vous avez le temps réfléchir oui on
sait si vous êtes une femme
je sais pas
continuer les attendait c'est pôle de
réflexion qu'il faut vivre ses fantasmes
jusqu'au bout ou que ça doit rester du
domaine du rêve qui dépendent nature des
fantasmes je parle fantasme en général
c'est pas uniquement ils font d'asthme
sexuelle savoir tassement général non on
ne parle pas que de ça ici je suis bien
compris alors moi c'est pas du tout les
missions d'un lac et y est importante
c'est une histoire extraordinaire et
romantique je suis pour eux d'après
jusqu'au bout il n'a encore une question
si non on va s'arrêter là je pense que
[Applaudissements]
vous restez avec nous jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission mais avant d'accueillir notre
invité suivant
je voudrais
parler de votre avenir politique parce
que finalement nous on sait pas vous
pensez que l'avenir politique sinon vous
ne vous ne seriez pas là nous on n'en
sais rien je suis là on est ravi que
vous soyez là bon on parle beaucoup du
fait que vous rejoignez le parti de
charles pasqua et philippe de villiers
qui s'appelle le rpr mais bon il ya un
peu des problèmes parce que villiers vie
je veux rester numéro deux et la pauvre
fille se faire piquer sans job de numéro
deux c'est normal et puis lui ici les
souverainistes et vous vous êtes
européen quand même non alors est ce que
vous serez un jour maire rpf de lyon on
n'en sait rien quel est l'avenir de
votre parti la droite qui quand même
avec 2 % d'intentions de vote aux
européennes ce qui va obliger à renoncer
et on a appris cette semaine le départ
du numéro 2 de votre parti fraises qui
dit maintenant le front national et
l'arrière était laminé la droite n'a
plus de raison d'exister donc pour
connaître votre avenir politique
linda va vous tirez les quarts
[Musique]
il
alors vous êtes vous avez déjà consulté
une voyante jamais pensé que les hommes
politiques
jamais jamais jamais ton sont prévoyants
entre un mâle vous êtes les lignes de la
main
nous en choisissez cette voulait donner
face cachée aulas il faut penser à
quelque chose il faut être un peu plus
là je vous sens qui lui croit pas ses
cartes face cachée
du vallon vous est 7e avec arnaud nom
m'a tiré le portrait
linda ça a priori comme ça ça vous ça
vous dit quoi ça c'est pas
c'est pas mauvais ya le pic c'est vrai
que pas donc là on voit cadets pour
prochaine prochain 2 millions des
circonstances favorables un projet
professionnel vous êtes
il ya un homme qui est généreux tu m'en
serve borgne il n'est pas borgne thierry
charles pasqua c'est peut-être charles
pasqua créé là pour vous aider donc ça
se passe assez bien et
oui ça se passe assez bien et en fait
il ya quelque chose qui peut arriver
d'assez important pour votre avenir
politique c'est déjà discuté avec le rpf
non
parce que c'est très positif mais faut
demander à linda y voit alors par contre
on sent qu au départ ça commence assez
bien donc vous avez le soutien de
quelqu'un mannum d'un homme d'un certain
âge à ne plus de 50 ans
et ensuite
il ya ne alors je sais pas si c'est une
rupture un découragement
laquelle il se passe quelque chose de da
cdh assez compliqué alors peut-être que
vous êtes à découvert
non ils appellent pique la balle fils
donc en fait alors c'est la détériore
c'est aussi la détérioration de certains
liens alors peut-être cette orientation
avec des liens passés c'est peut-être
cette personne par son aide et votre
association avec cette personne qui va
faire que vous allez que certains liens
du passé voici des simples nda clc
pasqua obligé charles millon a laissé
tomber son parti
voilà pour rejoindre et puis finalement
les 10 de coeur le set de coeur tout
s'est très bien passé c'est très très
bien ces rencontres amoureuses alors ça
c'est un grand succès et le soccer le
set de coeur saigne le nombre est
généralement liée à la famille et
notamment aux enfants mettez une carte
sur le site de coeur
à le pic non mais ça c'est une sas et
l'herbe
c'est dire qu'ils ont surgi votre votre
avis c'est à dire vous allez plus maître
de l'air bon en abondance non là
j'arrive pas à l'aise dès cette année
je sais pas même pas une fois pour
goûter vous pouvez re mathieu excusez
moi j'ai rien mais bon ça me permet une
autre carte celle ci
parce qu'en fait le roi de pique donc là
c'est lié à l'amour le roi de pique
annonce une
un avocat
tu vas l'emprise ombre
c'est un avocat huissier
je ne sais pas là la vie à l'amour donc
bon mais par contre ça se termine assez
bien l'as de trèfle ckoi linda l'as de
trèfle c'est c'est un succès c'est une
récompense bon ça va alors enfin
globalement ça va ça va assez bien
battre andy a très bien
merci villedary
djamel on en est rendu c'est y pas de
savoir si vous allez remplir le bataclan
facile à remplir le batteur a dit lu
plein le bataclan est encore loin de là
faut pas dire ça ah bon on a du temps
car il faut du monde ouais combien 80000
personnes beaucoup c'est ce que fait
céline dion en un soir oui
mais vous restez avec nous 1 donc le
focus va être un peu moins sur vous mais
pour vous pourrez rester là dire
absolument tout ce que vous voulez on va
recevoir maintenant quelqu'un qui
s'appelle jean rachid alors jean rachid
sais pas si vous vous le connaissez jean
rachid non mais tu auras sheets un mec
marrant c'est à dire c'est un type qui a
fait un disque qui s'appelle parodie zia
qu'avec lui reprend comme ça il fait des
parodies de chansons de rappeurs et lui
trouve en fait que les que les rappeurs
français c'est-à-dire les par exemple
stomy bugzy 10 et le dorothée du rap
français lui pense que stomy bugzy doc
gynéco ça c'est une expression très à la
mode le dorothée des beurs
c'était pas la dorothée de thierry
ardisson non je ne crois pas
donc doc gynéco passi stomy bugzy aurait
tout seul ministère amer il trouve
qu'ils sont un peu ringard parce qu'il
chante finalement des trucs qui sont un
peu guimauve un peu walt disney quoi et
est lui en revanche il veut que ses
chansons disent quelque chose il veut
lutter contre les clichés qui sont dans
dans le rap français alors ces derniers
ce qui est présenté par dieudonné je
vous conseille d'acheter le disque est
très très bien présentées par dieudonné
en la chanson qu'on va écouter ce soir
c'est mon papa à moi voici jean rachid
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait moins peur à moi et d'eau et p
il a voté pour jean marie le pen sortie
de droit tu ne dois pas une folle tous
les aider il m'emmène à vitrolles
fatigués des élections à jp dickes c'est
pour se reposer mais
ai-je fait des clins d'oeil quand
l'ascenseur bien mais il est obligé
parce qu'il en ait un il m'a offert un
jeu de fléchettes avec une carte de
l'algérie pour que je m'entraîne à tirer
comme lui
pour le cas où il irait à
mantes-la-jolie
agressé le maire avec ses habits et dire
au tribunal qu'il ne l'a pas touché même
s'ils avaient des caméras étaient
braquées sur toi mon petit papa et moi
je te crois il me donne des balles pour
tirer sur les biches et des conseils
pour coller les affiches
mais seulement quand le salam la
chercher quand tu me parles de la guerre
il me dit que c'est rigolo hitler et
klaus barbie sont ces super héros mon
papa est gentil il aime pas les méchants
sa couleur préférée c'est le blanc quand
il entend par pont on leva mort parce
qu'il a beaucoup trop d'argent pour
qu'on dise qu'il adore
[Musique]
mon rapport à ma et d'eau et p
pis le voter pour jean marie le pen n'en
a pas
eto'o
mon papa à moi et aux effets
il est doté 12 ans marie le pen tu sais
les rives histoire touche pas à ça si
les gens n'avaient lui le sauraient pas
voter pour moi tu es l'ignorant des
électeurs ça rapporte à l'appel alors
fais pas le con situe toujours ton fusil
à noël le savoir est une arme maintenant
tu sais qu'il est important que ceux qui
votent pour moi soit désarmé ben
j'arrive au pour deux trompettes les
gens me prennent la tête à la chasse au
sanglier les gens viennent me parler
bébé ton père m3 gamine a déjà tué un
petit bruno mégret après je vois ta tête
sur les jours d'autres comme un facho
qu'on peut pas traîner devant les
tribunaux qu un hôpital à elle en veut
toujours t'écraser on peut même plus
poussé quelqu'un dans la salle pour
rigoler cellules et simic ruse ça pour
le moment je t'expliquerai pas version
la seconde guerre mondiale une fois plus
grand et s'ils continuent à t'énerver
dealer bien que tu les huit caisses en
afrique bardot qui vient nous
[Musique]
ouais
merci
à qui vont passer aux gens
bonjour à l'eau est
oxydé par le 10 à 15 ans mais c'est bien
là en allant à l'ancienne la vérité
c'est qu'on a reçues le cd et qu'on aura
trouvée c'est génial on dit faut
l'invité séoul hier vous le savez je
demande d'applaudir jean rachid merci
merci
merci mille
chansons lauriers à l'oreillette on me
dit par exemple on m'a dit voilà là tu
vois là ça devient un peu lourd là ça
fait un peu mais là j'ai pas les mêmes à
fond sa voix se voir qu est-ce que l
excuse moi si je ne sais pas si c'est ce
que vous pouvez faire un truc à
te faire way et même s'il
connaît pas un
c'est toi tu as faim
et ben ouais c'était l'année où le mec
qui parle au micro exactement
je suis un robot mais enfin quand à
l'encrage et aucun talent moi je fais
que ce qu'on me dit dans leur catégorie
et aussi la
majorité tout ce qu'il faut qu'on est
donc maintenant on me dit ça c'est toi
jamel donc maintenant on veut dire
l'oreillette justement on m'a dit que
l'on va accueillir quelqu'un quelqu'un
qu'on aime bout alors je vous expliquais
un truc dans cette émission cette année
avec catherine barma on a pris une
grande décision c'est en variété
d'inviter les gens qui nous plaisent
voilà c'est clair simple net et précis
et on adore et voilà celle qui vient
d'avoir le principe c'est d'inviter ceux
qui nous plaisent à une vedette ou deux
pas plus par émission et ce soir ben
j'accueille quelqu'un qui nous plaît
beaucoup son surnom c'est la sole aux
yeux bleus c'est joli la sole gc qui
s'est tu sais qui c'est c'est axel red
mesdames
[Applaudissements]
il
bonsoir voila enfin charles millon il
n'arrive jamais laquelle la reine donc
voilà alors axel dont il y avait deux
derniers cd qui s'appelle toujours moi
il ya beaucoup de bonnes chansons il y
en a deux qui sont personnellement chez
égoïste 1 c'est mon show voilà il y en a
deux que j'aime beaucoup c'est ce matin
et et faire des mamours voilà ce qu'on
sait pas vous concernant c'est qu'en
fait vous êtes auteur compositeur
chanteur et comme vous êtes une fille
les gens devraient dire aux deux
composite 2 chanteuses sinon moi votre
c'est décevant bien
je me plains pas ces règles étaient
c'est plus calme très franchement mieux
qu ophélie winter par exemple je ne
connais pas ces chiffres mais je le mien
se porte bien alors non un problème
justement c'est le bébé parce que
problème mais je sais pas le problème
c'est surtout son voyage annuel voilà
mais comment peut-on appeler un enfant
janelle mais comme ça ton enfant mais
oui et tout le monde l'appelle jamais la
cause de toi
grâce à toi et j'ai lu j'étais au maroc
qui on m'a dit que jamais elle jamais eu
ça veut dire beau ouais mais ça mélangé
l'appeler jamel et j'ai moi j'aime moi
je l'appelais janelle et j'espère moi
jamais mais parce que c'est jamais
jamais je ne
me suis jamais plaint de chansons plus
je sais mais des vrais jeux j'avais
oublié que c'était quand même
elle était maudite oui à l'école des
beaux-arts est comment va galérer
sa galère je vais vous dire la vérité
j'ai lu dans le pire des ddd magazine
un magazine à scandales amérique voilà
c'était une histoire je vais pas vous
raconter laquelle parce que sinon
janelle elle pour appeler à
l'importation mais c'était vraiment un
article à scandale et je voyais le nom
et jeux wii et prier et j'aime beaucoup
jamais alors je me dis je non la b la
nature elle si vous voulez bien est ce
que votre mari ça que ça se passe
comment
ces millions ma fille je l'appellerai
john l c'est magie théâtre barry white
men
[Applaudissements]
avec vous dans la rue ça se passe bien
c'est de chasser caf vous l'avait
épousée dix ans après votre premier
baiser ce que cammas est fort on a
hésité longtemps
il en a pas marre votre mari parce que
je regardais quand même moi je ne sais
pas le soir avant de vous coucher vous
prenez b1 b2 b3 b6 du magnésium du
potassium du calcium
boules quiès dans les oreilles masque
sur les yeux et ça fait 10 ans qui
comporte à la fois des chaussettes
messieurs des choses
c'est de dormir en plus c'est pas que sa
situation il a le choix au minimum et
pied ou miage ou mais les chaussettes et
ils préfèrent ne pas massés au pied ça
dépend c'est comme quand je propose est
ce que ces objets de cuisine où on va au
mcdonald's
malgré des chaussettes malgré les boules
quiès le masque sur les yeux le
magnésium le calcium du potassium cv
comme disons que ensemble ouais mais en
même temps ça paie et on regarde comment
les jo nous les jeunes on met il à hilla
et je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
patience c'est de ma maison
vous avez une chose en commun c'est que
vous avez tous les deux étaient des
grands fans de louis de funès tout à
l'heure j'ai comparé à coluche qu'on
peut aussi dire louis de funès et vous
aussi vous avez 100 comment j'ai appris
le français en regardant louis de funès
mais oui bien défini j'adore vraiment me
battre est-ce que tu vois pas non plus
qu un truc exceptionnel
qui aujourd'hui apparemment les plus
possible d'après ce que j'ai entendu je
m'éclate et lui son personnage pendant
pratiquement plus de 20 piges et une
extraordinaire qui vous fait rêver
bourvil et louis de funès
mon temps quand il joue dans des films
comme l'a fait des grandeurs style vous
verrez aucun des marins comme un
visiteur sont un film qui me dire un
truc sur les taux n'est ccc comme le
disco c'est comme ouais je veux dire un
moment donné ça ce n'est pas bien de
dire fallait dire des choses maintenant
on la marine est à la mode
c'est exactement c'est exactement comme
guy bedos jouer juste dit qu'ils sont
que contre mon intelligence qui nous
oppose systématiquement dans la presse
interposée puisqu'on ne voit jamais je
les aime beaucoup mais voilà j'ai même
guy bedos mais maintenant bon alors on
va passer maintenant on va passer accès
et en sort vous allez ça va être dur
pour vous peut se compter pas sur
millions pour vous aider dans ce qui
arrive maintenant au lieu de parler de
choisir des chansons de soldes starks
d'otis redding steve cropper enfin
toutes vos idoles comme ça isaac hayes
ça vous connaissez par coeur à votre
maman avait tous ses disques donc ça
serait ça serait trop facile
on va pas non plus vous passer du david
baccarat d'aion warwick et tout ça parce
que tout ça vous connaissez par coeur on
appris des chanteurs ou
des chanteurs qui sont roux des
chanteuses en sont rousse au moment va
sur la pochette casser une myriade bas
vous avez sur la pochette un parce
qu'après il a pas d'efforts où vous êtes
vous êtes blonde vous je suis ouvert qui
n'est pas très joli titien que la
majorité des européens sa
vache d'arc a quitté rennes avait les
cheveux que de vaches ou vert kaki et ce
avec hilda est une vraie bruno
drum pourquoi recèle ça va très très
bien merci l'ambition votre nom c'est à
cause des cheveux ou à cause de petits
seraient des
c'est l'ascenseur ouais j'ai commencé à
vraiment fils à 10 ans aurait été bien
utile si ça aurait été mieux que jen
elle alors donc on a commencé vous êtes
prête vous vous concentrez méjanelle va
pas être nous regarde john lange suis
désolé mon t'appellera djamel puis c'est
tout moi j'ai un ami qui vient d'appeler
sa fille chloé on est content alors est
ce qu'on est prêt à s
la lumière
voilà aller tester test le test alors
didier tu es prêt premières chansons
plus un bon
[Musique]
morceau n'est pas roi
c
ma soeur nous sommes montés des points
oui bien sûr c'est vrai il ya des prix
aussi bien un prix social ça s'étire et
qu'ils soient
les rouges alors mais là où cela est
rousse et les rouges on l'a dit les
roues voilà on a dealé les roues donc je
pensais le cd de la hausse au pour que
tout le monde puisse voir effectivement
qu'elle est vraiment route
ça bougeait bien
alors il faut rien dire de mal sur la
route saut je dis ça pour vous qui la
connaissaient pas spécialement ce
qu'elle met des coups de poing à
[Musique]
trôner en mesures beaucoup plus dures
parce que c'est un personnage endémique
chante non très étrange mais
pas moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette affaire
[Musique]
c'est pour ça non
c'est pas de la jackson interrogé sur on
n'a pas non plus à la danse aussi j'ai
versé introuvable enfin là au moins vous
le sachiez nenê 6 et ouais comment tu
sais ça il a vu sa fiche il est venu à
bout d'un moment j'ai pu voir ta fiche à
les dates et là il a pas vu ma fille
mais comment il cessa lui c'est moi g
unit la merde
[Applaudissements]
c'est une fille qui n'existe pas un
personnage en 3d un peu comme lara croft
comment elles existent avec très connu
et très connu sa maison c'est un
personnage en progression assez sympa
sur mtv très souvent voilà oui
comment un individu regarde
j'ai de l'argent maintenant j'ai le
câble
c'est vraiment mon disque que c'est bon
pas encore et c'est très très bien là
bravo wayne rooney fort il est fort joli
nom avec lui le test non liquides ils
disent à quoi alors maintenant on
continue contre didier
[Musique]
pourvu qu'elles soient douces ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui est ce que jamel est
ce que vous avez déjà lu les paroles qui
sont au verso de ce disque là pourvu
qu'elles soient douces non
je ne vais pas le dire on
diminue mais non je serais même moi je
serai là c'est vous connaissez pas vous
avez jamais eu la présence d'esprit de
retourner le jeu c'est dsk
moi j'ai pas les céder pourquoi pas mais
c'est une chanson en fait sur la sodomie
non c'est vrai ouais franchement t'aime
bien mais là tu exagères là c'est une
chanson sur la sono je trouve que c'est
vrai tu as cherché en tête
chanson numéro 5 didier
poil de carotte
[Musique]
amadeus est une mission c'était une
punition c'est zéro tétouan j'ai essayé
tous les canadiennes
toi
scène canadienne avec des lots ce soir
je l ai beaucoup chez drucker jolicoeur
et
le loto qui a écrit pour la belle et la
bête notre dame de paris voilà il a
écrit que ce soit
bel
[Applaudissements]
et bien
non seulement elle a donné la réponse
mais là j'ai la biographie juste avant
ça c'est deux fois
ces deux points comprendre l'intérêt
accepte vous êtes en train de faire un
score fantastique
concentrez-vous
oui mais non il a d'un petit peu didier
surtout sur nikki
[Musique]
caméra
rgb
[Applaudissements]
voilà le dise de mylène farmer pour que
vous puissiez lire là vous puissiez lire
les paroles au verso on s'intéresse
alors je m'aperçois moment que jamel lit
les paroles de pourvu qu'elle soit où je
vais montrer à la caméra sic et voila
voila nichane mais niki voilà isabelle
boulay mesdames messieurs et la nappe à
eschert wilshere nous le montrer parce
que ça vient ça vient d'être trouvée je
pense que c'est une nouveau après be les
fruits bon on continue alors quand même
jamais ainsi l attendait
c'est pour ça avec toulouse les frères
s'est fait tout se passe à jamel ga ga
la pochette c'est parce que je veux pas
être accusé de tricher c'est ça j'aurais
pu tout mais c'est pas vrai
madison elle dit ça dans sa chanson non
oui j'aimerais lui dire
mylène je savais pas moi qualité comme
sa 1000ème je pense qu'elles vont
éventuellement revendre la médaille si
tu m'écoutes sache que j'aime bien tes
paroles
c'est vrai jésus dubois jouera jusqu'à
au hockey mais c'est passé pas obscène
sachez tous et touché mot côte à côte
pour des phrases essaie de les dire
non et re continue donc on continue avec
la dernière chanson
oh quel héros ceux ci un gaz
c'est pas c'est pas mon domaine
[Musique]
c'est par où ce jeu cache
là je peux te dire
c'est l'original
ses habitants
paris
france 6 points et ça fait deux points
pour notre ami djamel pas mal fait on
pas mal
de points 3 non mais parce que 2000
pauline ester wilshere et kenny un
chercheur trois points mais changer peu
les jeux de suite les achète voisine
trop bien
bon axel vous restez avec nous djamel
vous restez avec nous charles vous
restez avec nous on va passer à la
séquence suivante on peut remonter les
lumières merci et j'accueille stiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis par
linda hardy vous connaissez pas vous
avez canal quand tous les cas djamel
vous connaissez sûrement ça axelle red
jean billon sinon alors christine arron
médaille d'argent au relais 4 x 100 m a
sévi c'est pour avoir un petit peu quand
vous invitez on peut le dire vous avez
quand même si ça fait plaisir bah ouais
j'espère que ça fait plaisir en toile
c'était très content bien sûr eu bien
sûr attendre un appel beaux arts mais
non c'est bien j'étais restée très
content c'est à dire que même temps une
course enfin ça dure dépanneur pour dire
mais c'est faux ça est très long dans
votre tête c'est non ça va très vite
c'est vrai que ça très vite surtout un
sens mais bon c'est moins de 11 secondes
ça que ça s'est passé très riche
mais pour un truc qui dure dix secondes
ou est ce qu'il ya c'est quoi en fait on
travaille toute l'année pour une course
qui va durer c'est ce qu'ont - non c'est
assez fou donc il faut pas rater
l'événement il faut être propre et on
pour se croire bas gagné un pouce à
gagner bien sûr mais si on s'en sert
chose en fait justement pas défaitiste
quoi sinon ça va pas on va vous regarder
courir et pierre apprend continuerons à
discuter magnéto serge
[Musique]
e
question
une question qui me turlupine
est ce que bon le passage du relais
est-ce que c'est sexuel
jemmapes que je vois toutes ces filles
qui se passe machin comme ça je me dis
non je vois pas ça comme ça quoique ces
questions c'est pas tout une sur deux
j'avais pas pensé à ça c'est vraiment
bien joué c'est vrai que le donneur et
un receveur c'est comme ça les gens
qu'il ya transmission des cieux
je crois qu'elle va quand même beaucoup
plus vite maintenant
ouais ça me faisait donc j'ai jamais
pensé non j'ai avancé du tout à ça mais
c'est vrai que je vois c'est de cette
course là vous étiez dopé ou non non
jamais je n'étais pas dopé non non ne
vois pas ce que ça te va pas si de ma
façon de voir le sport je vois plus un
sport propre et avec plein de valeurs et
je ne pense pas que ce soit utile
d'accueil on est français cela s'était
pas en france je n'ai pas de contrôle
sanguin pas de compte c'est vrai c'est
j'aurais pu vous taupe et tranquillement
que j'avais même on sais pas qu'est-ce
qui est protégé ou pas tout cas moi ça
m'intéresse pas bon c'est vrai que c'est
j'aurais bien aimé qu'à la fin de chaque
course et dans les championnats comme ça
il est contre 100 gay parce que
franchement je pense qu'il ya un bon
nettoyage à faire encore aujourd'hui un
médecin qui me disait que en fait ce
qu'il gagne qui sont les meilleurs ce
sont des gens qui se droguent pas mais
qui qui qui sont pas hypoglycémiques
sait gérer compris ce qu'il a dit
penser qu'il
ya beaucoup d'américains qui souhaite
s'attacher forcément déjà été dopés déjà
sur moi là moi je veux pas tomber dans
ce système là et dire que les personnes
qui gagnent qu'ils sont d'avoir moi sont
dopés ça pas du tout je pense qu'on est
capable de faire de très belles
performances ensemble avoue alors
apparemment oui voilà
affirmatif quand ya pas de contrôles
sanguins quand chaque des contrôles
d'uriné envoie pas le bo exactement ya
voyant audi en maniant de référence
voilà des symboles de joie
non mais je peux gagner j'ai gagné l'an
dernier à budapest qui étaient sur leurs
hôtes
et j'espère bien être championne
olympique championne du monde sans
attendre on
[Applaudissements]
vous dit sans drogue et que l'on
applaudit comme si c'était
extraordinaire superbe oui je veux c'est
magnifique c'est bien rennes par rapport
aux autres à budapest dont vous avez été
championne d'europe du 4 x 100 m vous
êtes drapés dans le drapeau français
parce que avez-vous dit avait pas de
drapeau guadeloupéens oui je suis
française mais avant tout guadeloupéen
non mais je n'ai pas pris de drogue
d'armes ou de libérer sur les drapés
dans le drapeau guadeloupéens non non
non non non ça sera ainsi tant que la
guadeloupe n'est pas indépendante
j'aurais pas ma drapé dans un bois dans
un drapeau ou à louper vous êtes
indépendantiste que s'ils voulaient
claquement je suis pas indépendantiste
pas du tout parce que bon je sais très
bien que la guadeloupe a besoin du
soutien de la france c'est vrai qu'on
voit tout et catastrophe il peut y avoir
un guadeloupe et tout ce qu'on a besoin
de construire donc je pense qu'on a
besoin de la france et je suis une
guadeloupéenne française voilà pourquoi
est ce que vous dites que quand vous
gagnez vous êtes française et quand vous
perdez vous êtes antillaise c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est ce qu'on dit en général
c'est ce que disait journalistes et
voilà quand on a gagné ce sera la
française a gagné la médaille d'or
et si je perds ça serait quand la
victoire de la loi j'ai l'accord
additionnel
quand il est génial on dit qu'il est
français bien sûr bien évidemment bien
évidemment
on dit surtout quand tu quand il remplit
des salles et tout ça c'est normal vous
êtes très star des cheveux censure on
voit d'une couleur différente vais
installer coquet avec coca paraîtrait
assez positive c'est une femme et pour
une sportive cherchez pas amélie
mauresmo ou quoi je tiens voilà c'est
tout
non mais juste et les hanches fontaine
mieux le paysage déjà
la dalle et des baumes amélie mauresmo
oui au tennis
c'est ce que je voulais dire oui quand j
avais qui est bon que tu avais compris
quoi rien d'autre à voilà donc vous avez
l'envié de coquettes c'est vraiment le
cheveu vous avez toujours en appel à 30
verre de chaussures ah non je n'ai plus
peut-être mis à l'encan qui mêle d'un
marcos et 3000 la femme du dictateur de
philippine vous êtes à combien de paires
de chaussures lacées paradis tu ne sais
pas si ce n'est pas par moi que chez les
juniors tellement oui mal à suez - qui
mène de la marque au cc ligne ont le nez
vous un petit ou un petit piercing je
vois pas manquer du mignon il est tout
petit mais il est là le tatouage oui
j'en ai deux que taiwan à la cheville
qui veut tout seul qui n'a vraiment web
situation que n'a pas de signification
il n'ya pas c'est indécent j'en ai
ensuite à l'épaule qui signifie c'est
l'orgie de l'épaule on peut le voir
changer de la route et franchement c'est
bien l'ancien que voulez télécharger pas
il est juste là qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est la symbol alors en fait de
l'or
non elle est très branché dix jours vous
êtes aussi quand même ce qu'on ne
saurait par la mairie de paris s'avouant
sponsorisés pardon excusez moi monsieur
des boules ça vous embête pas de vous
montrer avec jean tiberi non un moment
parce que moi en fait je suis plus à qui
la mairie de paris parce qu'en fait je
envie de promouvoir mon sport et par
l'intermédiaire des amériques paris j'ai
cette occasion la de promouvoir mon
sport d'extérieur entre dans la pièce je
suis pas je suis pas là pour être avec
jean tiberi c'est plus une image
sportive que je vais véhiculer et je
suis surtout pas dans aucun parti
politique que ce soir ça se parle
l'auteur prépare elle
alors donc vous avez un garçon enfin
garçons jules quoi qui s'appelle dan
philibert oui un qui est champion de 110
m haies
honnêtement vous arrivez à rester
fidèles avec tous ces beaux athlètes
quand vous voyez dans l'est dans les
vestiaires non mais c'est pas bon en
fait ouais bien sûr nom est pas
j'ai pas spécialement une tentation
des sportifs qui sont beaux mais j'ai
l'habitude justement de voir de beaux
athlètes donc maintenant ça devient plus
plus courant qu'on arrête donc vous vous
dites que vous seriez prêt à tout
abandonner pour un homme dans les
limites du raisonnable qui en fait en
tout abandonner c'est pas vraiment
raisonnable voilà donc c'est quoi la
limite du raisonnable je ne sais pas
c'est
cochard nous a dit tout à l'heure c'est
sentir faire quelque chose pour lui mais
ça me dérange franchement il faut qu'ils
aient un compromis et que sa foi si
quelqu'un de demandes tout abandonner je
le ferai pas moi mais si tu serais mon
choix personnel je pourrai alors
maintenant ce que je vous propose c'est
de voir dan philibert donc qui est le
vôtre compagnon on peut dire s'est
mariée vient c est votre fiancée c'est
d'ailleurs justement on dit gandhi que
pour les garçons l'acte sexuel et
recommence recommandé avant l'exploit
sportif est ce que pour les filles c'est
pareil non moi je suis jamais jamais
spécialement entendu ça je pense que la
meilleure chose tu as déjà se sentir
bien ou aussi on a envie de se libérer
avant une compétition et que ça ça nous
des stress comme ça devait bien y faire
quoi il faut pas vous poser des
questions ce que tout le monde tirait
alors mais moi non mais attendez
moi j'ai les enfants alors maintenant
serge magnéto on regarde ben philibert
c'est l'histoire de deux paysans qui ont
deux champs l'un à côté de l'autre et
ses chambres donnent sur une sur une
falaise
et danses et chants et des chevaux donc
il y en a tous les jours il ya une
sécheresse qui tombe comme ça et
et tous les jours y perd un cheval donc
il a un petit peu dégoûté parce que son
voisin à côté il a toutes ces choses là
bien au complet donc il va voir son
voisin il lui dit des voisins comment
vous faites moi tous les jours je perds
un cheval où ils sont tous là au complet
vous avez un secret oui j'ai un secret
oui j'ai un même dans mon champ lan
pedro
oui m'expliquer un peu parce que je
comprends pas comment ça fonctionne
pedro lan arrête la chute des chevaux
c'est pedro pedro lan arrête de chute de
cheveux
pedro s'est fait trop mais bon c'est
pedro
op non tu vas pedrola n'arrête gilles
des chevaux visiter il est drôle à
s'entendre et bien tous les deux à
vous et des ménages et non pas encore
parce que tu vois maintenant que les 800
mille francs par mois à
fontenay-sous-bois a marqué lui il
habite toujours attrapant même
le nom personnes
non mais non non c'est parce je gagne
pas ça par mois déjà
donc fontenay-sous-bois c'est très bien
c'est vraiment sévère s'est calmée mais
moi même un manque de place maintenant
pour ça que j'ai envie de déménager moi
aussi je vais déménager avant pour aller
où du côté imposable de la ville de
trappes
jamais le côté obscur pourquoi attrape
pourquoi pas paris parce que c'est bien
c'est comme si j'habitais au bureau sais
pas comment tu expliques l étude des
gens et puis tu vas travailler direct
c'est bien d'avoir un petit coin en
retrait mais à des petits coins sympas
parce que je pense mais là où je suis je
te jure c'est vraiment bien en dehors de
ça c'est la classe alors dites-moi
dernière chose la vie parisienne est ce
que vous êtes comme jamais elle pour qui
c'est un petit peu le un peu les hébreux
qui adore le veau d'or quoi un peu un
peu le côté obscur comme il dit la vie
parisienne sont mes filles est-ce que
vous en méfiez vous fois disons que
c'est une ville spéciale points surtout
pour moi qui je viens d il donc c'est
vrai qu'au début quand je suis arrivé à
paris c'était vraiment très difficile
tout était ce pillage et mauvais temps
surtout ouais en plus où il faisait
froid donc c'est complètement différent
de la guadeloupe donc c'est vrai que moi
au début j'ai vraiment eu du mal à
m'adapter je me surprenais des fois
marcher vite comme les gens alors
comment je suis super bien avec en cours
et s'est vite plus vite que les joies
mais un gala mais dans la vie je suis
vraiment beaucoup plus cool tranquille
pour faire tout ce que j'ai à faire quoi
et c'est vrai que là je sais bien
pourtant ça va me dit vous êtes
puissante mais pas très nerveuse non
c'est vrai enfin nerveuse par
comparaison sur la gère mais des fois je
m'énerve its dites moi gecina rang vous
avez dit en bon parce que je parlais de
la vie parisienne mais il faut quand
même vous faire accepter déjà bougé les
très forts vous disent que vous disiez
je regarde pourquoi tu me regardes tu
dis oui je sais non mais je ne sais pas
parce qu'en plus vous parlez très bien
enfin nom vous dit emmanuelle béart à
une prétention qui ne déplaît
parce que oui bah c'était dans sa façon
de parler sa façon d'être qui me passe
et laissez passer qui vous déplaît c'est
sa prétention non non non c'est juste sa
prétention c'est très bien dernière
question les invités qui sont autour de
cette table où les voiliers dans quelle
catégorie d'athlétisme 100 millions par
exemple vous voyez faire quoi
[Musique]
j'ai pas pts et le lancer de poids mois
peut-être lancer du javelot
en attendant c'est ouais lancer du
javelot lancer de javelot djamel fait
attention à ce que tu pars rapporte
jamais bientôt lancer de vannes quoi
je tiens même peut-être
100 m 100 m sans langue et son langage
moi j'ai fait c'est pourquoi y'a
toujours un grand
concours a effectivement en belgique
chaque année et on va j'ai chanté pour
les vannes ouvertes heures et j'ai déjà
lancé le compte à personne voilà où je
sens la pression garé mon attention
[Musique]
évita
et atterri juste devant les métiers et
thierry ardisson
sur la tête à 800 le 800 way absent
alors de pro la huawei semer la licence
et un coin du sprint il faut toujours
les derniers oui et pourquoi parce que
sûrement pas le soir chez intel de
coureur de 800 bien merci sydney alors
vous nous ramener une médaille d'or ben
j'espère voulait pas que linda vous tire
les cartes pour on est vraiment sûr non
ça pourquoi pas non non mais bon à mon
avis il faut mais je m'entraîne bien
pour aller vite et
jean lyon on me dit dans l'oreillette ça
serait bien là comme une réaction de
charles millon est ce que vous avez une
réaction parce que sur quoi je suis pas
sûr tout ce qu'on vient de dire
n'importe quoi vous dites que vous
voulez c'est juste une réaction que sa
place à christine arron que si une
société veut s'ouvrir eh bien il faut
qu'elle trouve en fait des personnes un
peu emblématique et on peut remercier
christine arron de cette personne mais
voilà catherine barma
catherine barma merci alors maintenant
on va passer au flop du moment
c'est un jingle
les flops du moment qu est-ce qui est
flop en ce moment pour vous charles
millon qu'est-ce qui présente le rpr
depuis depuis la mort de de gaulle ya
plus que le bordel qu'il soit général du
rpr et robert russell chez le seul qui
fait du pognon avec leur père qu est ce
qu a d'autres pour vous comme flop je
donne un exemple de flop le flop le fn
fait un flop parce que puisque je parle
du domaine que je connais bien c'est la
droite parlementaire qui fait flop oui
fait flop c'est la raison pour laquelle
démocratie claudique que vous avez la
partie gauche qui se porte bien et puis
la partie droite qui est paralysée me
slajic et me
flanque en ce moment pour vous à par
ophélie winter a déjà parlé ça serait
pas sympa
non pas du tout non non non je vous
demande ce qui vous semble se calmer
mais l'onu l'équipe de france je
resterai dans mon domaine moi je crois
que mon club ce qu'est ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est les disques
qu'on peut sceller compagnie ce qu'on
peut copier je veux dire ça enlever les
l'ailé droit l'e3 ou aux auteurs et aux
compositeurs voilà voilà
je lui le schpountz demande dans les
films du riz n'a pas forcément oui
j'aime bien ça j'aime bien smaïn j'aime
bien azéma j'aime bien est situé le
cadeau que j'aime bien au riz j'ai vu de
ce putsch et qui fait mais ça va passer
c'est dommage que le public est pas
soumis à wii
un jeu l'aide
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il fout anelka matin deux
minutes chéri il arrive l'attendait le
cas il prend 200 millions et toi tu vois
la même réaction que tous les bouffons
de journalistes là qui le lui le pauvre
ils arrivent ils à 20 piges il n'est pas
responsable de cette pression il arrive
danger l'équipe du real de madrid où
tout est déjà très bien établie il faut
qu'il fasse ses marques il est effet ces
déclarations sont les autres joueurs
comme quoi les autres joueurs étaient
médiocres n'ont jamais beaucoup parlé
ans non c'est pas vrai non vraiment sur
l'état c'est quelqu'un de calme d'assez
réservé oui au oui/non véritablement ce
n'est pas son style et je ne peux pas
parler pour lui mais je le connais assez
bien et je suis très content de ce qui
lui arrive et mais il est illettré c'est
un très bon joueur et on en reparlera
dans trois semaines la semaine d'accord
bon ben ya là il ya un truc est pas un
flop c'est l'émission de guy bedos a
tout à l'heure sur canal avec florence
belkacem vous l'avez vu j'aime bien
ghibaudo sur moi pour moins que ça là
aussi on l'a dit lui même beaucoup qui
pousse - tirait à huawei je voulais
juste dire qu'ils aillent y redit son
but contre mon intelligence
systématiquement presse interposée
puisque si vous jamais je les aime
beaucoup
merci ça dort jamais l'édition tout cas
on s'est marré c'était génial voilà
alors maintenant on passe aux deux jeux
de la vraie vérité c'est à dire que on
va vraiment tout se dire la vérité ici
sur ce plateau ça va être une expérience
assez étonnante qui n'a jamais été tenté
la télévision alors évidemment ça
s'appelle personne ne m'en il faut
réalité oui et pour présenter ce jeu de
la vérité ce jeu de la vraie vérité nous
allons accueillir celui qui à la
télévision il ya quelques années avait
inventé le jeu de la vérité patrick
sabatier
vous connaissez vous connaissez linda
hardy j'ai vu à au cinéma et à la télé
de la télévision c'est vous qui était
allé voir rectoverso voilà non on était
petit c'est sympa parce qu'en fait le
film a fait 300 mille entrées pas prier
aux anglais système ecc6 en plus
malheureusement j'étais pas qu'un
spectateur payer un jeu développé
injection comme il
faut dire quand même les choses il n'a
été dans le film était vraiment
excellente c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'elle était assise ici ce soir ce film
n'a pas été complètement san marti
l'objet d'une question d'ailleurs sans
doute jamel debbouze que celle raid vous
connaissez c'est des gens que vous
recevez sûr vous avez reçues sur tmc
dans votre émission axel oui on a passé
une heure et demi ensemble
heures et puis
à l'égard des démissions est prêt je
l'avais menacé de semaine c'est l'une
des meilleures émissions que j'ai fait
moi aussi moi aussi moi aussi j'ai
regardé la cassette le week-end suivant
les sources que ça dure cinq minutes en
graissant minutes sans minutes et moi
aussi ce que tu veux mais les questions
sont super attaque
c'est bon ça lui
oui on est très contents ou c'est là
alors le jeu de la vérité à l'époque la
télévision ça a été un événement
considérable en souvient tous de coluche
assis sur un sur une chaise haute géante
répondant en direct aux questions des
téléspectateurs qu'est-ce qu'elle comme
autres moments comme ça d'abord il ya eu
le premier de l'an aujourd'hui 1985 de
l'ong qui n'avait donné son accord
environ huit mois avant en disant tu
viens me chercher c'était à l'aéroport
les rennais john r et il m'a dit tu
viens me chercher le 10 janvier le rouge
de fret en émission et le 11 il a fait
l'émission en direct et c'est vrai que
c'est lui qui a déclenché en réalité
merci monsieur delon parce que c'est lui
qui a déclenché la notoriété du jeu de
la vérité il ya eu 15 bourouis et puis
il ya eu évidemment on peut pas ne pas
en parler chantal goya de 9 avril et sa
carrière
je crois que
tu crois qu'ils ont vraiment raconter la
vérité écoute je vais te dire que la
plupart du temps avant l'émission il me
demandait de ne pas laisser passer telle
ou telle question pas tous mais certains
parce que ça les touche est trop près et
j'ai toujours respecté à respecter ça
c'est parce que je pense que quand on à
vis de quelqu'un il faut le respecter
avant tout et donc c'est sûr que non il
ya même eu des gens donc je ne vais pas
citer leurs noms mais qui n'ont pas
voulu le faire parce que ils avaient
peur les questions oui en tous les cas
s'il fallait une sacrée force de
conviction pour convaincre des grands
artistes comme cela de venir à la télé
de s'asseoir en direct et d'avoir des
gens qui leur pose le public qui leur
pose toutes les questions moi sans aucun
projet ouais en gros succès tu pourrais
le faire bien sûr
il ya ka chantal goya que ça pas moi
j'ai pas compris chantal parce que quand
on a fait la répétition l'après midi ça
se passait bien je crois que c'est le
soir qu'elle a dijon il a prêté des
plans
elle a pété les plombs en direct alors
là on va faire le jeu de la vraie vérité
donc il n'est pas du tout le concept de
patrick mais je voulais que patrick soit
là parce que dans le genre en vérité
c'était très fort alors vous connaissez
le jeu 20 nitoo 3 heures du matin on
avec des copains un peu torché et puis
on se dit voilà on va maintenant on va
se dire les choses
il faut pas toujours être torche et
comme vous dites pourquoi se dire les
choses bah disons que ça peut aider
d'être un peu touchés mais s'ils ne
savent pas
était clair on peut quand même posé une
question préalable est ce que la vérité
est elle toujours bonne à dire c'est une
bonne question est ce que est ce qu'il
faut toujours cela dit il faut essayer
c'est ma première question je peux la
pause m 6 millions balancy alors
[Musique]
et alors là tu as que la vérité tout est
elle toujours bonne à dire qu est
ce que vous vous avez toujours dit votre
vérité la vérité
je pense qu'il ya des vérités qui ne
sont pas bonnes à dire parce que la
personne qui est en face de vous ne peut
pas la supporter dans certains cas la
délicatesse l'amour la charité veux que
vous passiez un acte de restriction ça
c'est normal je crois que dans une vie
de couteau dans une vie de groupe dans
une vie publique coûteuse vie privée on
a tous ressenti ça mais c'est un geste
de délicatesse alors pu me poser des
questions à tout le monde c'est le
principe voilà alors djamel pouvez me
poser une question je répondrais la
vérité peut demander à linda vous paraît
y voit là et bien là parce qu'elle
question n'apportent questions et les
gens diront la vérité pourquoi tu
détestes guy bedos
ouais non c'est vrai je pense que je
sais même plus pourquoi je les teste dur
dis moi pourquoi non franchement je sais
pas
je sais pourquoi moi pour me dire ou
alors parce qu'ils sont prêts ils
avaient apparemment refusé toutes les
invitations oui bien sûr mais ça mais au
départ pourquoi je sais pas c'est vrai
tu sais pas enfant je prends le déteste
pour rien parce qu'ils m'aiment pas
voilà parce que dans la vie et des gens
qui vous aiment pas là vous les aimez
pas attendre c'est gratuit voilà très
intelligent non voilà une question
j'aime bien les problèmes tant de
questions
[Applaudissements]
j'ai cinquante jamais seul une deuxième
est ce que ça il est venu voir votre
spectacle oui vous l'avez vu vous
féliciter wii no ma paye jamais si je te
jour il n'est pas venu me féliciter vous
avez pas accepté qu'il vienne on rentre
dans votre loge quoi oui oui vous n'avez
pas accepter qu'ils vendent dans votre
moi j'ai pas que j'étais que smaïn mais
là je te jure
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais te dire tu veux te dire ce
qui s'est passé est véritablement c'est
un quiproquo
sincèrement arrive oui vraiment à quoi
un quiproquo ce défi de chercher dans le
dictionnaire
est-ce que voilà les trognons brûlés
flam on sait bien qui promet l'entente
n'ont vraiment mais alors alors
et le but c'est de mieux voir les
spectacles et en fait je l'avais en face
de moi et non oui ils rigolent ils ne
voulaient pas parce que y il analysé le
spectacle et rire et jamais je ne savais
pas je savais pas que je m'éclate royal
est vrai spectacle il ne riez pas je
vous aime oui mais je savais déjà trouvé
le nom de vos premier one man show c'est
vrai
oui c'est vrai oui
non mais oui mais ça y est au sprint
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour son
travail pour lui ok il ya aucun problème
et je toujours d'un bilan plus aucune
animosité simplement quand il est venu
voir mon spectacle parce que moi je
regarde tout le monde quand quand je
joue je regarde les gens dans les yeux
et lui il est en passe de - iriepa est
comme ça mais que j'aime bien je me
disais mais pourquoi il rit pas à cette
image et du spectacle comme ça quand tu
es non mais moi je pense qu'on peut
applaudir
quand il évoquait dans la loge il pas il
abrite être dans la bonne loges
on voit la
charmille ont posé une question qui vous
voulez une petite maline comment l
éphémère gens mis en jeu posé des
questions à vous mais à moi aller à
jamel allez-y
quand vous préparez une émission comme
ça oui
choisissez commun en fait les
participants bas s'ils voulaient le
prince d'abord je les choisis pas tout
seul j'ai choisi et catherine barma et
ailleurs - si on en parle on en parle
tout le monde en parle et finalement
c'est vrai que on fait un petit peu le
principe c'est un peu comme un dîner en
ville on essaye de mettre autour de la
table des gens qui n'ont pas grand chose
à faire ensemble
et voilà donc pour essayer de créer dé
créer des mélanges de genre
comme un dîner en ville il ya toujours
un archevêque une
je vais vous pensez qu'on aurait pu
s'inviter des uns des autres mais juste
pas patrick tata pas des boules ne pas
être france données sur tf1 ah ouais si
je peux que je parle pour toi je te
piste à se questionner la wii si
j'aimerais bien venir et pourquoi tu
reviens pas mais bon moi moi je serai
perçu en outre on a vécu c'est pas moi
qui ai choisi un regard ce jeu on
demande maintenant est en train de
retard au temps contre la montre a fermé
les portes haute à leurs hôtes à barrer
le passage oui c'est sûr on a dit non tu
ne feras plus télé chez nous parce que a
ouais enfin en réalité on ne va jamais
vraiment demandé qu'on m'a ça arrange
pas mal de gens que je n'y sois pas
voilà c'est une kermesse qui merci
d'avoir répondu avec cette franchise je
peux dire en ce qui me concerne que je
ne comprends pas pourquoi patrick
sabatier aujourd'hui n'est pas sur une
chaîne jour j'ai bien sûr habitude de
cirer les pompes mais je comprends pas
moi non plus
haut ses couleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les suissesses ta place
le plaisir je fais des tournantes et que
patrick christine je veux vous poser une
question sur l'une des personnes du sexe
opposé à christine voilà comment tu
t'entends avec marie josé pérec pas
spécialement bien ce n'est pas du tout
mais alors c'est excuse moi c'est une
bonne question une très bonne réponse
je vais te dire excusez moi j'espère la
ta place mais je te parle c'est parce
que je pense qu'à chaque fois sur jeu
parce que vous l'avez remarqué mais dans
une situation il ya toujours un traîneau
il ya deux personnes qui sont assimilés
il ya eu hinault et fignon et eu de
longs belmondo de lui un moment donné
brucker et moi jamais à vous pacino
l'arena marie-christine et marie josée
et c'est sûr que quand si on parle
maintenant on ne peut pas vraiment aimer
l'autre on a un peu en rivalité oui et
en plus la presse nous même rivalité les
années je pense que pas à pas
nécessairement quoi pas nécessairement
je veux dire que mon mari jo je n'ai pas
comme concurrent direct a fait du 400
mètres moi je fais du sprint aux cours
mais il ya toujours eu ce problème entre
nous moi je peux avoir des copines qui
font du 100 m je veux dire sur la piste
bon là ce moment là on est plus copine
c'est moi qu'on arrive à elle et moi je
pense qu'on peut faire la part des
choses je peux dire j'aurais pu être
copine avec elle sans pour autant qu'ils
aient enfin cette animosité contre
l'annoncé des différences qu'elles
portent entre guillemets un peu à la
france en allant s'entraîner à los
angeles trouvé que c'était un manque de
respect non pas du tout c'est son choix
elle a envie de s'entraîner aux états
unis voir ci dessus mais je voulais voir
mickael s'entraîne à los angeles et ma
façon plus belles là bas les qua non
c'est vrai que c'est une femme c'est une
femme les cas
ce
qu'il y ait encore des questions que
vous avez envie de vous poser les uns
les autres
profitez-en parce que ces gens ne
sauront jamais ce nom pourrait le
redevenir époque risque qu'on me foute
n'a pas la grosse tête avec tout ce qui
t'arrive parce que tu es quand même
assez jeune tu as quand même un bon
succès auprès auprès de tout le monde
j'ai la grosse tête on est je l'assumé
pleinement c'est quelque chose que je
veux bien que les matins de
non ça manger avant la grosse tête c'est
quoi ces histoires à conter manqué voilà
voilà
bon oui on a réussi donc on considère
que les autres sont inférieurs on les
traite pas de la même façon au monde
sait ça sincèrement pour l'instant non
mais sachez une chose et je préviens
tous mes proches que si par malheur je
vais tourner un jour aux states à la
sagesse ou un le loc c'est la merde pour
vous parce que là je vais la prendre et
ça me tue
on peut rallumer les lumières vous devez
résider
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cela fait
que ce que je ne trouve pas ce
ralliement 10
tu es
tellement loi ni temps de sommeil tu
pousses dans tous les sens
ça fait
36 fois que je partais les dessins
qu'ils font
c'est en vendent
et les montants michaud ne sait rien que
maman t'es moche à
dire toi car mange pas
[Musique]
la soirée type témoin je voulais pas les
mamours
mois
[Musique]
je fournis par les mamours
jusqu'au
michaud
scheer
nouveau site
[Musique]
tout
je touche je freine portant secousses
pour moi c'est tout
et
[Musique]
certes j'ai pour me fatiguer moi c'est
toujours patate
je sais en vain
t
je ne sais rien
gilles michaud
[Musique]
irv et toi
carmaux jetant
la soirée pop
eater complet
[Musique]
je continue
voulait pas les mamours
maman hamon
je voulais pas des mamours
[Musique]
richaud
tu vois
[Musique]
je voulais juste
un
témoin
[Musique]
timo
maman
[Musique]
les mamans
les
[Musique]
jours
axelle red je voulais faire ainsi des
mares faire des mamours merci beaucoup
merci d'ailleurs recherche kalfon c'est
un bon moment si l'image pouvait devenir
aussi voilà convives voilà est-ce qu'on
peut mettre le jingle voilà et l'image
rose
[Musique]
fréquentant bars alors j'ai décidé
jeudi jeu là j'ai décidé de me faire
plaisir voilà d'invités mais dieu les
gens que j'aime et de me faire plaisir
c'est normal non voilà
notre ami djamel donc et au bataclan à
partir du 15 septembre
évidemment tous y aller 3 novembre le 3
novembre vous êtes au zénith axel c'est
ça c'est le 3 novembre au zénith non
voilà il faut tout gérer aussi voilà
donc l'émission est terminée on va faire
un petit bilan 1 e
mais c'est bien ce genre kevin na merci
perfectible mais par malheur elle est
pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais tirer les leçons de cette
émission se séparer un petit bilan jamel
pour ma part cette émission faisait
passer un petit peu à la halle à l'arc
en ciel
parce que l'arc en ciel c'est beau c'est
sympa ça fait rêver autour de cette
table avec des gens sympas bon on avait
le sourire du début jusqu'à la fin ouais
personne n'avait pas retiré personnes
est parti en vrille ouais même si à un
moment donné charles millon
[Rires]
un petit bilan la première émission mais
moi personnellement j'ai un peu trop
parlé non si on n'a pas toujours très
bien compris mais vous avez
100 millions est ce que vous êtes
content d'avoir rencontré djamel très
content bien mais c'est maintenant qu'on
a décrété de quelqu'un de bien et qu'il
était formidable et avait un beau
sourire ça va maintenant ben disons que
ça va m'aider à faire la deuxième
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
mais c'est une nécessité encore
voilà écouter chao adieu à ses vous
c'est vous qui voyez si ses adieux tant
pis et si c'est charles rendez vous la
semaine prochaine et 1 demain si vous le
voulez bien merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sourit ce matin
rezaie
côté cour je sens si bien je me plais
soins
on l'a fait le père
je payais
qu'alain
jeu sommet
[Musique]
las
un point que je paie
qui mon cas
[Musique]
aucune porte mais je me
rappelé
dechy
oui
[Musique]
je sais bien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu